[Music]
hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive so it's time
to see what's making the headlines with
sonia soda the chief leader writer at
the observer and christopher hope
associate editor for politics at the
daily telegraph so a very good evening
to both of you very pleased to say that
you're going to be with me here until
just before midnight
so let's take a look at what's making
the front pages and ashes of a dead land
the guardian leads with the words of
ukrainian officials who accuse putin's
forces of indiscriminate fire on
civilians in mariopol as a mass exodus
of the city intensifies
ukrainians regain key territory forcing
the russian army to retreat in several
locations
but raising fears that putin may soon
turn to chemical weapons that's what's
on the front of the daily telegraph
exiled ukrainian protesters onboard a
dinghy and holding flags marked no war
have tried to block abramovich's super
yacht from entering a port in turkey
that's according to the metro
the financial times says the chancellor
rishi sunak has planning to set aside a
large part of an unexpected 20 billion
pound boost to the public finances this
year rather than helping families hit by
the cost of living crisis
the daily mail though focuses its
attention on calls for the chance of
rishi sunak to ax what's been branded
the worst timed tax rise in history
well the star leads with the story about
what they say is discrimination against
people with cockney accents
and a reminder by scanning the qr code
that you can see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us
and so sonya soda and christopher hope
with me to go through some of those
front pages and sonia
we're picking up with the a few of the
front pages are still leading on the
situation in ukraine the guardian being
one of them you've picked this out first
of all and
the grim headline ashes of a dead land
russia lays waste to ukrainian port and
this is the ongoing bombardment of
mariopol in the south of ukraine
that's right so it's a guardian report
from aviv which is um which is a city in
the west of ukraine that sort of is
relatively safe compared to the rest of
the country and is acting as a route for
refuge for people looking to leave the
country but lots of the ukrainian
refugees who've been arriving there um
hoping to get out of the country to
safety have been coming from mario pole
um and so this is a report or first
person accounts of what it's been like
to live in mario pole over the last few
days and i have to say i mean it just
it's described like hell on earth um so
there are families who've talked to my
colleague who's written this report who
describe what it's like to have lived in
a basement for days on end while there's
been shelling going on surviving on a
few scraps of food between you dirty
water this family that was interviewed
um they feel very lucky to have made it
out alive um you know they say it was
sort of chance that they managed to get
out someone sort of said that they knew
a way out
um and i think it just speaks to
um how dreadful you know the tactics
that the russians are using they're very
very similar to tactics that they used
in syria when they intervened in syria
it's besieging a city like mario paul it
is
subjecting it to constant bombardment
it's targeting civilian targets like
kindergartens like hospitals like
psychiatric hospitals we know that this
has happened and this is really it's a
campaign of terror to try and get
citizens to um you know to surrender
well yeah and and christopher those
details just are horrendous and if we
turn to the daily telegraph um it's
when you read a slightly more optimistic
headline it almost jars doesn't it
in contrast to those you know
witnesses accounts of what they're going
through because the daily telegraph's
main headline is ukrainians regain key
territory in fight back and that chimes
with what president zielenski himself
said today he talked about being on the
brink of survival
that's right and of course there is the
fog of war which you must never forget
that amazing piece by daniel buffy about
rotting corpses in the streets of mario
pole is what's on the ground now you
step back helicopter view of ukraine
it's not going so well from vladimir
putin we're approaching the one month
anniversary of the war breaking out the
invasion i should say of ukraine
happening by russian forces and look
what's happening it looks like the
russians are retreating in several areas
despite fears that putin may turn to
chemical weapons we say in our headline
that's been mooted for a few days now
hasn't happened yet and thank goodness
but we report here how we're quoting the
ukrainian defense ministry that its
forces retook america for town west of
of kiev um despite a fierce battle there
and that's why it's so important i mean
it has not happened in the way they
thought this special military operation
which putin is trying to convince
russians was a good thing well it's not
happening there are lots of people dying
lots of russians are dying um at some
point uh he'll get his reckoning for
this just not not just yet but this is
positive if you if you take what ukraine
is saying for
what's happening well yes absolutely and
let's move on to um to look ahead to
tomorrow now because a lot of the papers
do lead with um the chancellor rishi
sunax options ahead of his uh spring
statement tomorrow and the financial
times is the paper you've picked out
first of all which as you might expect
makes this their front page story
they're suggesting that
a boost to the public finances um that
has come about
is going to be saved by rishi sunak
rather than spent aren't they tanya
yes that's right so there's 20 billion
pounds extra in the coffers more
headroom
than was predicted this time a year ago
and the financial times is saying that
he might spend some of that on
alleviating
the pain for households facing a cost of
living crisis you know
huge increases in energy bills housing
costs etc
um but that he's going to save most of
it um one would assume to spend closer
to election time
i think this would be the wrong thing to
do there's lots of demands on this pot
of money so lots of people are calling
for him to scrap the national insurance
rise i actually think that's the wrong
thing for him to do because the national
insurance rise if you scrap that
it costs 9 billion pounds more than half
of that goes to the richest fifth of
households so it's not a very good way
of spending your money wisely to protect
the lowest income households of people
in the low paid jobs who are really
really on the brink i mean what they're
facing is really terrible so what other
think tanks have called for is for the
chancellor instead to spend that money
on increasing tax credits for low-income
households
because the moment those levels are
going down in real terms because of the
rising cost of inflation well let's
let's deal with with national insurance
and what you think of that christopher
because it does actually feature on the
front page of the daily mail they
they're saying you can spike the hike
rishi and that's going to chime with
quite a few back benches actually who
think that it's the wrong time to
introduce a rise in national insurance
what do you think do you think introduce
it but then mitigate against it for the
poorest or do you think not introducing
what's your take on it
he's on the hook here isn't he the
problem is if he delays it by a year he
saves 12 billion pounds great the
problem is he then puts the national
insurance rise which which has to happen
we're told to pay for um nhs for three
years and then after that social care
right on the eve of a 12 month countdown
to the may 2024 general election so what
do you do more likely i think he's going
to fiddle with the thresholds so it will
take those on the lowest where he's out
of national insurance in the same way
that out of it
if they pay income tax the government
set aside what thursday for a big day in
parliament a three-line whip to use
language eye talking and that means lots
of mps have been called back for some
big voting something big will happen on
thursday people i too i speak to think
he'll play with these thresholds on
national insurance it's interesting
though isn't what sonia is saying that
does show there'll be a big debate here
between the tories
and the labor the tories will be trying
to say we want to put money away for a
rainy day his brief remarks from the
treasury overnight talk about increased
security of a faster growing economy the
security of a more resilient public
finances and that's what the
government's saying and sony's right too
of course building up a war chest for
tax cuts going to the next general
election and that's what the budget next
year is about the pain now and then the
then the good stuff later on well yes
and sonia you were saying that you think
that the money should be spent now but i
suppose the other argument again is
looking at how much had to be spent on
the pandemic i mean billions i mean can
the chancellor afford to carry on
borrowing and keeping on spending
well there is this extra money that's
extra headroom and i do think that that
he needs to do something for households
you know for people in low paid work
they're in minimum wage jobs that means
you're struggling and you're having to
make really difficult choices at the
moment some of them between you know can
i afford to switch the heating on or am
i going to put food on the table these
are you know we've got lots of families
using food banks making very very
difficult decisions so i think the
chancellor's got i mean i doubt he will
but i think he really should be focusing
on those households and the alleviation
that we've seen him give already around
energy bills through the council tax
rebate through this um you know this
sort of loan that households will pay
back that actually you know the council
tax rebate 150 pounds a year that goes
to four fifths of households so it goes
to i mean everyone's finding it tough i
know but it it's very it's spread that
support very thinly when it's really
families and minimum wage jobs who
really need the most support so i just
you know i doubt he's going to do it
because he's he doesn't tend to make
these calls he doesn't tend to direct
support to the um to the you know the
very hardest up but i think that's
absolutely what he should be doing
because when you look at energy bills i
mean the average energy bill is it's
crazy how much it's going up and you
know if your energy bill goes up by you
know 400 500 pounds a year when you're
on a minimum wage job i mean you just
don't have that kind of leeway in your
budget well yes and we just saw the
guardians take on it chancellor just
stand by hard-working families
christopher but it's not just that your
energy bill it's that the cost that that
puts on your food everything that's
transported around the country you know
it's all going to be hugely more
expensive and the bank of england saying
that inflation could go into double
figures by the end of the year is the
chance that are going to do enough so
that people can cope
what is really really hard i mean
outside of westminster people are
looking at the the prices on their
petrol stations changing uh i've heard
of them changing three times in one day
one pound seventy for it for a um a
liter of unleaded uh 50 quid to fill a
fill a fiat 500 this is a lot of money
for ordinary people to do or anybody to
deal with frankly not anyone to deal
with uh frankly i mean
and the guardian is being giving um the
chance of the benefit of the doubt in
that headline you quote there to stand
by hard working families is promising
security for them um
they'll be hoping there'll be some
targeted help and that's why i think
this threshold idea has has a lot of
mileage right now in westminster but
there might be a rabbit certainly um we
haven't even talked about defense by the
way yet now i think that the issue of
defense whether that should go from two
percent of gdp to three or four percent
that is the next big debate but we're
told that might happen in the budget in
november and by then well who knows
what's putting up to you by then it may
require urgent funding before that
certainly some lots of very difficult
decisions for the chancellor to make it
fascinating to see which way he lands
tomorrow and we're going to take a break
right now lots more to talk about in
just a moment including could there be a
u-turn on onshore wind developments to
ease the uk's energy woes we'll talk
about that just
[Music]
[Music]
with me tonight sonia soda the chief
leader writer of the observer and
christopher hope chief political
correspondent at the daily telegraph and
christopher we're turning back to the
front page of the daily telegraph now
your paper
and the the second story there is about
uh a push for onshore wind farms this in
the light of course of britain trying to
wean itself off russian oil and gas
so what's the paper saying
well this is like a retread of the
battles in the in the cameron years when
there was a big push on green energy and
then david cameron kind of gave up in
2013-14 in the face of an assault from
ukip over europe but at that point it
was all about new onshore wind farms and
the policy became offshore wind farms
and that's why you see these array of
windmills
all around around the british isles and
this new idea because of the soaring
cost of energy is to is to change
planning rules making it easier to site
onshore wind farms near communities this
will be a red rag so a lot of readers
the telegraph and people live in rural
areas who just don't want to see them on
their
on hillsides and near them and they will
not be happy about it and that's why
we're reporting tomorrow's paper a
cabinet split over this idea to tear up
planning rules um apparently um
sunak the chancellor of course are up
tomorrow in front of the commons for
spring statement
spoke in favor in a parliamentary debate
last year of of um of controls on wind
farms so he's he's quite an opponent and
not not surprising he is in richmond in
north yorkshire um so lots of areas
concerned and i think this shows how the
war in ukraine the russian invasion of
ukraine has changed all assumptions and
so really old ideas which were rejected
in peacetime no longer
well yes and we've still got to get the
outline haven't we of uh what the
government plans to do about its energy
provision
given
what's happening in russia and ukraine
let's move on though sonia on the front
page of the ft they cover um pno's
latest steps after sucking loads of
their staff
that's right so this is just a little
story on the front of the t ft about the
amount of compensation that piano is
making um available but there's been
other sort of news emerging today as
well
um so you know p have sacked 800 workers
behave really abominably i think with no
notice
and um apparently according to unions
they're employing um seafarers
from other places for as little as one
pound 80 a week so about 170 000 pound
figure i mean that starts only for a
very small proportion of um the um sap
workers who've got very very long
periods of service
government ministers have actually said
today they they've warned piano it may
face the threat of prosecution because
it has not played by the rules that this
on this at all it didn't give ministers
um the warning that they're supposed to
give when they're making uh more than a
hundred british workers redundant so
really really terrible behavior by pna
well yes and just to say i think you
said at 1.80 a week i mean it's 1.80 now
which is still not very much
being paid to this replacement workers
just to be clear there and i think we're
out of time i think i'm being told are
we out of time
we've got 30 seconds can you do 30
seconds on civil servants want to do the
school run christopher go
i'll be really quick uh a union is
saying that a civil servant should be
allowed to work around their life events
and things like the school run so work
from home and go and pick the kids up i
mean if a lot of people in the private
sector that's quite difficult to
understand because many of us rightly
are back at work or have to be back at
work so it's so it's
yeah it seems unfair to some people but
you know why not if you can get away
with in a civil service okay you did
brilliantly there with my time
constraints thank you both i'll see you
again at 11.
[Music]